What can they do to take time and space
for themselves to pause and just think
and sort through their ideas?
What they need to do is make their
breath the first word that they say. So,
rather than going straight into the
conversation, rather than just start
with the the word vomit, the let me
spill out my ideas,
if you just take a breath
right before you respond,
what it's doing is not only regulating
your body,
you know, making sure you're more aware
and in control of your emotions,
it is signaling to the other person that
what I'm about to say has been thought
about, has been acknowledged.
There's a difference of you asking me a
question, "Hey Jefferson, how was your
day?" And I went, "It was good. It was
good, Chris. It was fine. It was fine.
It's a good day."
Doesn't really sound like I
really thought about it. But, if you ask
me, "Hey Jefferson, how was your day?"
and I went,
"You know, Chris, it was good. It was a
good day.
Ups and downs, but it was good." Which
one of those sounds like I actually
acknowledged what you said, really
thought about it, and it's and in
exchange you actually want to hear what
I'm about to say more. Like same thing
with in an interview. It's probably one
of the top things I talk about with
friends that are going into an
interview, and they're like, "Hey, what
should I do?" It's like,
"The slower you answer the question, the
better the interview will be." They ask
you a question, and you just immediately
try to It has to be as fast as possible.
That's the opposite what you are needing
to exude in that moment is I can take
stressful moments, including the
interview that I'm in,
and be able to regulate myself, and show
you that
I'm not somebody who runs in
conversation, I walk in it. And whenever
you slow yourself down, they're going to
find that what you're saying is they're
going to even feel that what you're
saying is more thought out and more
intentional than if it's just off the
cuff.
To the best of your ability to recall,
when do you first remember this being a
conscious thought or effort from your
part?
I started teaching clients this very
early on
in my
uh really as a first-year associate.
Uh I was at a law firm that was the type
that
you know, I wasn't behind a lot of
partners. It was like, "These are your
clients. You either sink or swim. Get
after it." So, you really go to your
first trial your first year by yourself.
And I can remember training some of the
first people
on they get so nervous before their
deposition. There's cameras, there's
other people,
and I'm teaching them, "Okay,
instead of just going right into it,
they ask you a question instead of just
having an immediate response,
take a minute." And some I would say, "I
want you to just count one Mississippi.
That's it. Just
one and yeah, I mean, I did all kinds of
things to try and get them to remember
it. And so, then what I would do is I
would put on the hat of being the
opposing attorney. And I'd say, "Okay,
Chris, you know, you understand that
you're here today and that and that
true?" And I would start to kind of
pressure them
and get them all kind of worked up. And
I'd say, "Okay, this is the moment. This
is where count this in your head one
Mississippi.
Okay, now answer. Instead of feeling
like you're in their time frame, in
their time space, you're controlling it.
You're saying, "Nope, I'm the one that's
driving in my lane. You can't do
anything about it." So, it's really it's
like the teaching defensive driving
verbally and how to do that. Now,
on the flip end of that is I I'm a
fifth-generation
a trial attorney. All the men in my turn
family are attorneys, women, too.
And my dad is this way. I could come to
my dad with an issue
and I'd say, "Oh, Dad, we got this is we
have this problem." And he'd go,
"Yep. That's a problem." You know what I
mean? Like that he was just always
[laughter]
very very very keel. And so, I would be
I'd be like, "Oh my gosh, Dad, going to
be they're But they're going to be
really upset." And he was like, "Could
be." And say,
"Yeah."
"I guess they'll be upset." I mean, that
was just his type of demeanor.
And so, of course, it's just genetics
mirroring that my entire life.
Um he was he would always exude the the
run or the walk, don't run kind of
mentality.
I can feel my energy change just by the
way that you were changing your tone and
the pace in which you were talking. This
is just goes to to the point of like how
much the tone and the way that you
deliver the words matter sometimes even
more than the words. Cuz when you're
putting on that like um that mock trial
thing with the opposing counsel saying,
"So, what will you" I just felt like,
"Whoa." Yeah. I I like I'm going to say
something probably not that smart.
Probably something that's going to
incriminate myself right there. Right.
Right. Even if you don't mean to.
Yeah. I I just felt it right away
because your baseline is so calm,
reassuring, and and just gentle and
inviting that the minute that you switch
that up, I could feel it immediately.
I'm sure I'm not the only one. If you're
listening to this, just let us know that
I'm not the only person who felt Right.
Right. Right. Well, the thing is anybody
can do it, Chris. It It's I mean, it's
more natural to me because this is how I
was raised. This is the household I I I
was in. I mean, I was raised on on the
Socratic method. You know, I'd come with
the problems and my dad would say,
"Well, what do you think they would say
about that?" You know, like he would
always put it in the position of the the
other person and slow me down.
But it it Like if you're listening right
now,
if you want to sound more confident,
more respected
in your communication, and more even it
more serious, more warm, whatever it is,
all you need to do is slow down your
words and lower your volume. It makes a
huge
impact. If you are with somebody who's
always loud
and very aggressive, do you want to do
more of what they say or less? So like
compare it to to this.
If I were to say
"Look Chris, I already told you I'm not
I'm I'm not going to do that."
versus
"Chris,
I already told you
I'm not
going
to do that."
Now which one of those
is let's say
somebody who sounds more grounded,
somebody who sounds more balanced,
somebody who sounds more composed,
somebody really you don't want to mess
with.
It's actually the person who sounds less
emotional, the person who sounds less
aggressive
who says "Oh no, this is not somebody I
want to mess with."
And it's I'm saying the same thing
but the connotation, the feeling is very
very different. Okay.
You say it, I feel it, I live it.
But there's so many people who will hear
this and say like, "Gosh, it's just
I can't figure it out." Now you must
have worked with some some clients in in
the courtroom where you're like, "Okay,
just take a breath. We're going to go
real slow." And then you see them on the
stand and they're like,
That's got to happen, right? Oh yeah,
it'll happen a lot of time. Yeah. Okay.
And when you're on break, do you how do
you redirect? How do you get them in
that pocket again?
Yeah, so you kind of have to do it
without telling them about it. Like I
have
>> Okay. Um for example,
I had this guy once
who
um you know, he had read some stuff on
Google.
Yeah, he's like, "Oh no, I you know, I I
I read you need to be you know, really
short with your answers." I'm like, "Oh,
that's that's all great." And they on
textbook, they think they got it all
worked out. And despite all of my
preparation with them,
they got we had I had them go right into
the deposition. He started out great.
And it it took not no time at all,
Chris. He was starting to step on the
other
attorney's questions. So, before the
attorney was actually
and finished with their question, he's
already stepping on it with their
answer. So, he the
the question was something like
you know, now you went that day, you
first drove to your cousin's and you
like house. Yep, I went to their house.
So, he's stepping on the the words,
which you don't want to do because
in terms of the reason why there's a
court reporter is because everything's
written down. So, on paper, it doesn't
look good. It's what they would say it's
a messy record because you have these
insertions into instead of a full
question, a full answer.
And he kept doing it and I was like
you know better. And so, in my head I'm
like, all right, this next question I'm
going to pull him out. So, sure enough,
he answers the last question, stepped on
it again. I said, okay, let's take a
we're just going to take a 5-minute
break. Let's just take a little break,
you know, stand up for a second. He's
like, yeah, that's fine.
And so, we get out of the room and I
just say, hey, just walk with me. And
so, I'm unrolling a peppermint while I'm
doing it. Just action acting super
nonchalant.
I pop it in my mouth and let's just sit
right here. We sit down and I say, so,
um how old are your kids again?
And he was like, all right, yeah, you
know, seven seven and eight. I was like,
oh, that's that's great. That's great
ages. What what did you What did y'all
What did y'all do the last week? And all
of a sudden, he starts to like calm
down. He's like, oh, we
we went to a movie. I was like, what
movie? He's like, oh, it's the movie
with the you know, the talking animals.
I think it was like um
Madagascar. Yeah, something like that.
Madagascar 2.
I was like, oh, that's that's great. I
was like, was it good?
And he stops and he slows down and he
goes
yeah, I mean, it was good. You know, it
was a cute movie. And I said, good. All
right, you see what we're doing here?
He goes, "Yeah." I said, "That's exactly
what you're going to do in there."
I said, "We're going to slow it down."
He goes, "Ah,
I'm stepping on it, aren't I?" I said,
"Yep, that's exactly what you're doing.
All right, so let's let's go back and
treat it just like you're you're you're
talking to me right here." And sure
enough, he went right back He's like he
had to hear it. He had to feel it for me
to make him click. Rather than me
pulling him out and going, "Hey, stop
stepping on the question and and get let
him get it all out, okay?" That's not
going to do it. But, by showing the
example, making him feel like it was
or just right there, keeping it in the
pocket. I was like, "Let's let's stay
right in this momentum. You feel this?"
And he was like, "Yeah, I feel that."
Okay, let's stay right here. So, I used
that phrase in the pocket a whole lot
with him.
Okay. This is excellent.
Very interesting how you took it to a
very conversational level where there's
nothing for him to be nervous about.
Yeah. And so that he can be a better
performer in the courtroom because
there's Shouldn't be a difference
between this style of talking versus
like when you're getting grilled by the
other attorney. And I find that in
sales,
we can have a normal conversation,
everything's going great, but when
they're on a call with the client, they
get all high-pitched, they get really
nervous and anxious and they start start
talking really fast. They start doing
performative things that they normally
just don't do. So, are we talking like
there's this universal concept about
communication? Like, how you talk to a
really good friend is how you should
talk everywhere?
In my opinion, yes. Now, I would say
there's a difference in of course
context and environment.
I'm not going to talk to a prospective
client the same way I'm going to talk to
my grandmother, you know? Or or or uh my
best friend or my dad. There's casual
situations where when you and I are in
sweatpants and drinking coffee talking
about life, it's not the same.
So,
but I would say the premise holds true
that you generally want everybody to
feel very comfortable around you. Even
when you're public speaking, one of the
best compliments you can get is you seem
so comfortable up there. Yeah, cuz when
you understand that
I don't have anything to prove. I'm just
telling you what I know. I can be
excited about what I have to share.
And when I get excited about the message
of what I'm giving,
then I can channel that excitement into
how it's going to benefit everybody
else. And that that's a that's a
wonderful thing to be generous with your
words and generous with your message.
Now, if somebody is grilling you
in a deposition type of setting, it is
it is different. It just it's
understanding that you can't make me say
anything I don't want to say.
And you can't make me talk any faster
than I'm going to respond.
So, when I understand that I'm the one
that has control of the steering wheel
at all times, it's a very
confident mindset. It's a game-changing
type of concept. When you
you say something to me, I can choose
not to say anything at all. That is a
pretty powerful thing. People feel like
you always have to have a response. It's
not true. So, when you're talking in
front of people, even in that sales
context,
if you can just be you,
like we have such a sixth sense
of knowing when somebody's being fake.
I'll tell you what, a jury
knows immediately, Chris, if somebody's
being fake, and they will destroy them.
They will pour their whole case out if
they feel like they're being fake. I
can't tell you how many times
I've seen a jury totally turn
on somebody's case if they thought that
they were being somebody that they're
not. Like you just meet somebody and go
there's something about them that
doesn't it's just this sixth sense that
we have. I think it's very
um
I'm not sure if it's just the DNA of our
caveman-like abilities to go, "No,
something doesn't smell right about
this. I'm not sure what it is, but
something's not
And it's even people who try too hard,
right? They're like, "No, they're trying
too hard." Like, what does that even
mean? They're they're being somebody
that they're not. Ever had somebody try
to really make you like them? And you're
like,
it makes you it's a it's a turn-off. Now
you definitely don't like them. Why? Cuz
they're trying too hard to be liked. I
don't They're being somebody that
they're not.
Uh if a witness on the stand is faking
sympathy, like trying to gain sympathy,
let's say they kind of act You can tell
they're being fake emotional about it.
They really don't mean it. Well, a jury
will just go, "Nope. We don't trust you.
No credibility. I think you're faking
it. And it's it's king's X
every time." If you enjoyed that clip
and want to see the rest of the
conversation, you can click right here.
Or if you want to see the latest episode
of the Jefferson Fisher podcast, click
right here, and I'll meet you there.